*sneezing*
♪ Heee heee he heeeeeeeeeeee~ ♪
Alright, here we go
*Awkward sounds*
What is happening, what did I do?
Where'd I come from, where'd I go? Where the fuck did the video go?
*Singing random tunes*
Are we - Are we alive?
Are we back?
Are we good?
Did something happen?
Are we still... is everything... oh God.
Why is that like that?
Why is that doing that?
Stop doing that!
Stop being a silly bitch for one god damn second, okay?
Hoooly shit, okay EUUUGHH
Eugh, I got Mickey Mouse hands!
Oh God! There's just dicks under here!
*Marks perverted sounds*
My meh-
Ooh-ho, I got grabby hands!
What's the first thing I'm gonna do?
♪ Doot doot doodle doodle doot ♪
♪ Fuck yooou! ♪
Oh that's nice!
Oh that's nice.
Ahh, that's nice!
*one of those weird mark noises*
*high pitched* Ooah that's nice!
*another weird noise*
*weird noises continue*
Okay so what about this?
What am I supposed to do?
MMMMMMWUUUHH
I REALLY GRAB THAT BALL!
FHUUCK YOU!
OOOOOOOOOOOH!
That was a responsive flong!
Eh~
Wow!
That's actually accurate!
You know it's accurate, cause I can't hit for shit. *shitty laugh*
Oooh, there we go
Oooh, what's it filled of?
Candy?
Head Lice?
Eh~
Dreams?
*Full Mark Rage Mode Activated*
FHUCK
OFF
EVERYTHING
I HOPE IT DIEESS
RAWR
CHUNKO MAD
MARKO ANGRY!!
MARKO WANT PAIN!
MARKO WANT PAIN FOR-
ENEMY!
RAWRAWRAWR
Oh.
Marco?
Polo?
*mouth-made transition noise*
Oooh! Wait, woah.
Oh!
*game horn*
AAH I didn't know- eugh, God it's so floody (?)
Oh God that's too much flood
Oh God my oozers need pumpage
*Sexual Mark sounds* I'm pumping as hard as I can!
BEAAHHHHHHH!
*afterglow*
EEEAAAAUUUGGHH!!!
*more heavy breathing*
OOOAAAUUUGHHH! OOOUUUAAAHHH!
That was soooo weird.
You're gonna get both cannons now!
NO!
NO PLEASE!
OH GOD!
*violent gurgling*
*splat*
Yep.
That's what you deserve.
That's actually cool!
What happens when I...
BLEEAUGHGHHH
FLUID SIMULATIONS!
Nice.
Splat clown painter.
Not!
Pretty sure that's not it
I'm pretty sure this is about j****ng in those  cl***s m**th until they explode all over their faces!
What - BLEEUAGHG
There's no way to not take this sexually!
BLLEEUUUUUUAGGH!
I suppose if you were...
You know...
Not an immature twenty-seven year ol- BLEEAHHHGH!
But how else am I supposed to do this?
Hey fucko!
Hey FUCKO THE CLOWN!
YOU WANT SOME OF THIS?
RAAAA!
Eigh- eh you saw what happened to him!
You're next!
AAAAAAAAAAHH!
Oh, it was a illusion!
He was next!
OOOOEAGHEAGH!
See? You're all dead now...
We're all ji****s now
wut
AAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHH!!!
Hey it's St. Patrick's day! KIIISSS MEEEE!!
GLAAAUUUUHHH - oh they're all out of balloons.
*another transition* Okay, what do we got n-
Ooh * sharp breath*  Ooh! I know how to do this!
OOH! Notch it! Notch!
OOOHH - FUCK A DUCK!
Errww shit.
That's less powerful than I thought it would be.
Fuck a duck!
*mark the goat*
Eeeh fuck you! Ooohp shit.
Eeeh fuck you! Oooh shit.
These are real arrows!
Fuck you! Wooah shit.
Haboink!
Hep-
Haboink! Hep-
Haboink!
Hep!
Wait..
*grunts and ehs*
Are these only worth one point a piece?
Ooh shit.
Fire 'em?
Woah shit, look at that!
Oh, I gotta f- aw, I gotta light them on fi - I didn't know I gotta light 'em on fire!
How was I supposed to know?
How was I suppo- I'm gonna repeat that, I want that one!
Can I get another?
Can I have another?
May I have another?
*through clenched teeth* Someone in the distance gonna get some!
Get lit on-
FIRE!
Heeeehhh~
Alright fine, fuck you.
What do you got for me?
Whoah- eeEHH fuck off!
Oh.
*excitement*
Owow!
*ninja noises*
NO BITCH! FUCK YOU! YEAH! ALL MY UNBRIDLED AGGRESSION FINALLY GETS TO BE RELEASED IN THE FORM OF CONFETTI!
AHHH!
AUAAHH!
AAAAH - I am the next Hokage!
HEYYAAAAA!
KIYOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOUOUOOUOUO! HAUGH!
*more yelling and flailing arms of death*
*even more yelling*
*still yelling*
*Markimoo is getting tired*
*heavy breathing*
I am the next Hokage
WORSHIP MY NAME!
I don't watch Naruto.
Okay, now that I'm sufficiently out of breath,
I've gotten my exercise in for the day.
Move on!
What do you got for me?
Ugh- Oh, hey!
Whack a Me-lo?
I'll take that!
Woah, shit.
Alright... Fuck, you, with, your, stupid hair
Your stupid hair. Is dumb. I hate it.
Woah. You wanna...
Hwah... haw byaw byaw!
*haw byaw byaw continues*
Holy shit.
Ha! Hey, ha, hoh, ha ha
Ho... the hair is so weirdly real!
*buzzer* Ahh! Aw, shit
43!?
I should've been hittin' from the flat side.
Uh! CHUNK NOT HAPPY!
MARKO WANT MORE!
Mwuhhhhh! Mwuuuuuuuuuhhhhhhh!
Aw fuck, you- bhdh wanna come with me!? Huh!?
You wanna mess with me!? Ah, fuck you!
Aw, fuck off, bitch! Aw, you think you gonna mess with me?
UWAH! Fuck off- UWAH! Get outta here!
I could think of liter- aaAAH!
Agh ed deh liver- AH! Fuck you.
Don't laugh at me!
Huh? Fuck of- ewUGH fuck off- euwwueghfUCK YOU!
You son of a bitch! You think you're gonna mess with me!?
Huh!? I- I fought in 'nam!
Hwauh! I don't even need to look!
*hwah-based noises*
They're comin' at me! They're comin' all at once now!
*more hi-yah noises*
Hey! Hey! HEY! HEY! HEY BEHAVE YOURSELF!
Boys! Boys!
Meh! Bweh bub buh.
Meeeehhh!
Man, who knew the Minions©®™ game would be so much fun?
Hey, hey, say banana!
Hah. Say Banana! Hey say the thing- c'mon, say banana!
Aw c'mon, that's my favorite line!
♪ Ba-na-na, Ba-na-na-na ♪
♪ Ba-na-na, Ba-na-na Ba-na-naaaaa! ♪
*exhales* I wouldn't be shocked if that was copyrighted.
What is that? Oh, shit.
I was just playin' The Brookhaven Experiment!
*light eh-ing*
Woo! Shootin' from the hips, cause I'm a cowboy!
I'm a cowboy!
Got big wide hips and a birthing... labia? I don't know.
Oh I'm a cowboy!
Fuck you in the face, then go suck a dick.
Oh. Oh I guess I- oooh okay.
Alright, I guess we're done.
Woah, Cannon Skeet? Eugh, I don't like the sound of that one!
With that weirdly sexual- woooaah.
BOINK! Ha ha, ha ha-
Woah... ah, got it. Woo! Nyah.
Boum!
Bounk!
I am so good!
Aw man. Look at me!
This is- like, legitimately, I've been- I've been makin' fun of this... a lot.
And, and havin' a good time with this but,
the fact that this exists, is really frickin' cool.
Woah, shit. This is breakin' it on it's own!
Too many frag-mants.
Like, legitimately this is just cool!
The fact that this technology- this feels real!
It just fe- it frickin' feels real! That's so weird!
That's so weird! That's so weird. That feels real!
My god. That's awesome!
I friggin' awesome!
I friggin' awwwwsome.
Oh shit. Oh! My score; I guess I'm done.
Oh man, that was fun.
But this was my score: 2 in clown painter, not very good I didn't know what I was doing!
4 in fire archer, I wasn't ready.
375 in balloon knight,  43 in whack-a-mole, 94 in boxing...
33 in shooting gallery, 42 in cannon skeet. So!
That is all... for now. This was...
A l- oh, hey! How's it going.
This was... oodles & oodles of fun. I had a blast playing this.
This was a ton of minigames, but still... it's the most immersive VR experience I've had yet!
Weirdly because... the graphical technology was there. Like, it's obviously made by Nvidia, so of course they're gonna show off with their fluid physics and hair stuff,
but... it added a level of realism that I don't often get with these games!
So, it was really fun! So, if you have a Vive, play this one, beat my high score if you can.
But thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought! In the comments down below.
Thanks again for watching, and as always I will see you, in the next video.
Buh-bye!
♪ Outro Theme ♪ *Mark awkwardly dancing*